[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle Tristan
Banon je suis auteur romancière
essayiste nouvelle liste scénariste
en 1988 j'ai 9 ans il est à peu près 6
ou 7 heures du matin et je cours
réveiller ma mère qui dort encore dans
son lit c'est normal à cette heure-là
la raison pour laquelle je veux la
réveiller c'est que depuis 6h du matin
je suis devant les dessins animés de la
5 de Berlusconi que beaucoup d'entre
vous n'ont pas connu
et les programmes ont été interrompus
par un flash spécial qui annonçait la
fin de la guerre Iran Irak
alors ici il faut que je dise que ma
mère est née athée errant et que son
père mon grand-père était un ingénieur
iranien qui a quitté le pays au moment
de la chute du chat
la France c'est pas n'importe quel choix
il y avait des pays beaucoup plus
intéressants financièrement il y avait
des pays plus simples mais la France vue
d'Iran c'est la liberté c'est la liberté
c'est l'égalité c'est la fraternité
c'est la laïcité tout ce qui n'existe
pas en Iran alors très tôt très jeune
même si je n'ai jamais vu le pays de
cette partie de mon arbre généalogique
très tôt pour moi ces mots cette devise
française a voulu dire quelque chose et
j'ai toujours eu ça on crée très profond
en moi ce désir de liberté et cette
nécessité cette pulsion presque à la
défendre
très tôt j'ai commencé à écrire écrire
sur cette liberté là sur cette
possibilité de la revendiquer cette
chance extraordinaire que nous avons
dans ce pays de pouvoir revendiquer la
liberté d'avoir la liberté d'expression
la liberté de dire
en 2000 Marjane Satrapi sort Persépolis
je sais pas s'il y en a qui se
souviennent vers ces polices c'est cette
bande dessinée en quatre tomes c'est le
premier tome qui sort en 2000 qui
raconte son histoire l'histoire d'une
petite iranienne qui va fuir le régime
des Mollat après la chute du chat je
dois à Marjane Satrapi de ne plus avoir
eu honte de mes origines de ne plus
avoir eu honte d'être iranienne et je
lui dois autre chose capitale quand on
devient auteur c'est d'avoir compris
comment la petite histoire sa petite
histoire personnelle peut renseigner sur
la grande histoire sur ce que nous
vivons tous comment raconter notre
présent peut renseigner sur la société
qui nous entoure alors très tôt dans mes
romans sous forme de fiction dans des
essais dans des nouvelles même qui
étaient souvent tirés d'actualité j'ai
voulu raconter les problématiques du
monde qui m'entouraient j'ai voulu
raconter une réalité
j'ai voulu raconter
ce qui se passait autour de moi et qui
mettait fondamentalement contemporain
j'écris aujourd'hui sur le féminisme qui
est le mien le féminisme universaliste
qui doit énormément à Simone de Beauvoir
et à Elisabeth Badinter aussi et puis il
y a la laïcité cette laïcité dont je
vous parlais cette laïcité qui est la
pierre angulaire de mon logiciel
intérieur
Elizabeth Badinter répète souvent qu'il
n'y a pas de féminisme possible sans une
bonne part de laïcité les conversations
que j'avais enfants avec mon grand-père
sur le régime des modes là en Iran
là-bas
l'observation du monde qui nous entoure
de la révolution en cours aujourd'hui
alors que nous sommes en train de nous
parler
l'observation de ce qui se passe en
France avec la montée des intégrismes
même si on refuse de l'avoir mon
convaincu qu'Elizabeth Badinter a raison
alors j'encre les mots je les écris à
travers toutes les possibilités qui me
sont offertes pour qu'on puisse en
parler j'écris des livres qui sont faits
pour être parler que la parole arrive
est une victoire de l'écrit que je sois
devant vous aujourd'hui est une victoire
littéraire
alors beaucoup de choses m'oppose au
féminisme de mon temps beaucoup ça n'est
pas si grave parfois c'est violent
souvent
je revendis qu'une filiation avec Simone
de Beauvoir Simone de Beauvoir elle
refuse l'essentialisation Simone de
Beauvoir refuse l'assination de la femme
en résidence victimaire quand elle sort
le deuxième sexe elle se prend des sauts
de boue
on lui reproche
l'honnêteté de son deuxième sexe on lui
reproche de s'être posé la question de
la part de responsabilité de la femme
dans son propre sort alors évidemment
elle n'absous absolument pas l'homme de
son rôle dans l'oppression du féminin
des années durant mais elle se
questionne à savoir
quelle est la part de permissivité dans
la femme a pu faire preuve à des moments
de son histoire et dont elle ferait
éventuellement encore preuve pour
autoriser
cette soumission
Simone de Beauvoir écrit qu'il n'y a pas
de liberté possible sans liberté
financière et on va beaucoup le lui
reprocher parce que même si on ne le dit
pas beaucoup il y a surtout à son époque
des femmes qui se complaisent ou en tout
cas qui naissait pas trop de sortir de
leur situation de femmes entretenues au
risque de s'alliéner
et cette remise en question cette
nécessité de se poser la question de
notre propre responsabilité dans le sort
qui est le nôtre c'est quelque chose de
difficile à admettre pourtant je pense
qu'elle a raison à chaque problème
d'égalité auquel je suis confronté je me
pose toujours la question de savoir
quelle est la part de responsabilité de
celui qui en subit les frais ou de celle
qui en subit les frais c'est pas du tout
pour l'accabler c'est pour essayer de
faire avancer des choses vraiment alors
évidemment c'est moins bankable surtout
sur internet que les propos radicaux qui
tendent à diaboliser l'homme comme étant
la source de tous les mots des femmes
sans essayer vraiment de lutter contre
les propos radicaux marchent très bien
sur les réseaux sociaux et donc
aujourd'hui très bien dans les médias
c'est moins bankable mais je pense que
c'est peut-être plus
utile
mon féminisme se revendique de
l'universalisme je vois le féminisme
comme un humanisme comme les autres
finalement alors l'universalisme
qu'est-ce que c'est parce qu'on en parle
beaucoup comme ça c'est souvent jeté
dans le débat et on le définir rarement
l'universalisme c'est cette idée que
nous sommes tous tous ici
des pensées des paroles des possibles
des actes et des actions au-delà d'être
des femmes des hommes des noirs des
blancs qui homosexuels qui
étaientrosexuels qui gros grand maigre
roux qu'importe l'universalisme c'est ça
tous les mêmes possibilités et c'est
avec cette idée chevillée à l'esprit
qu'on a pu obtenir l'égalité des droits
aujourd'hui depuis 2006 pour être exact
notre droit est absolument égalitaire et
ça n'est pas qu'un détail jusque 2006 il
y avait encore l'âge légal du mariage
qui était fixé à 15 ans pour les filles
et à 18 ans pour les garçons depuis 2006
ses 18 ans pour tout le monde encore une
fois ce n'est pas qu'un détail parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que partout où la femme est traitée on a
différents que l'homme
on est hors la loi ça veut dire que
partout où évidemment il y a viol
tentative de viol agression harcèlement
mais aussi partout où il y a plafond de
verre partout il y a discrimination on
est hors la loi
encore une fois ça n'est pas qu'un
détail mon féminisme celui que je
défends mon combat pour l'égalité ça
n'est pas de vouloir changer
l'orthographe ça n'est pas de vouloir
rendre l'écriture plus inclusive ça
n'est pas de chercher des boucs
émissaires en les accablant et en
décidant qu'ils sont responsables de
tous les mots des femmes parce qu'on a
une flemme monstrueuse de lutter contre
ces mots-là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué ça n'est pas non plus de
vouloir réécrire l'histoire pour
réécrire les contes pour enfants ça
n'est pas de vouloir censurer comme je
l'observe souvent non mon féminisme
c'est de vouloir faire appliquer la loi
encore une fois que notre droit soit
parfaitement égalitaire et ça n'est pas
le cas partout il faut pas l'oublier ça
n'est pas qu'un détail faire appliquer
la loi c'est demander plus de moyens
pour la justice c'est demander plus de
moyens pour la police parce que à quoi
servent des lois si on n'a pas les
moyens de la faire appliquer c'est un
vrai problème mais c'est pas que ça
c'est aussi la formation l'éducation
allez voir les enfants dans les collèges
dans les lycées dans les facs et essayer
de leur donner les clés de l'égalité
essayez de leur donner les clés du vivre
ensemble quelque chose qu'il faut jamais
oublier au-delà du féminisme au-delà de
la défense antiracisme c'est qu'on doit
tous vivre ensemble et c'est que là elle
passe aussi par la laïcité et d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire parce qu'il y a
de nombreux problèmes dans des écoles
comme la vôtre que le jour où les lieux
d'éducation arrête de vouloir défendre
la laïcité on a perdu et c'est l'égalité
qui perd en réalité
alors ce féminisme là
il refuse l'assignation à résidence
victimaire je vous l'ai dit et il
s'oppose à la volonté de certaines
féministes radicales de vouloir demander
des droits spécifiques puisque demander
des droits spécifiques pour les femmes
c'est très exactement le contraire de
l'universalisme c'est très exactement le
contraire de ce pourquoi tous ceux qui
nous ont précédés se sont battus quand
j'entends des féministes des féministes
pardon dénoncer la présomption
d'innocence en disant qu'elle est le
gilet de sauvetage des coupables de viol
parfois j'ai envie de leur répondre oui
oui ça arrive je vais pas mentir ça
arrive mais ça n'est pas sa vocation sa
vocation c'est de prévenir l'erreur
judiciaire
et cette vocation là elle nous assure de
vivre tous dans un système égalitaire
l'État de droit a mauvaise presse
surtout ces temps-ci où on a plutôt
tendance à vivre dans un air un peu
victimaire on cherche des victimes à
tous les moments de la vie néanmoins il
est notre meilleur assurance de vivre
libre allez voir dans des pays comme la
Biélorussie où il n'y a pas d'état de
droit vous verrez que les victimes elles
sont pas mieux traitées moi-même en 2011
quand j'ai porté plainte contre DSK avec
huit ans et demi de retard je dis
volontairement de retard parce que il
faut porter plainte si on veut obtenir
gain de pause pour avoir un maximum de
preuves
je n'ai pas obtenu gain de cause
la victime que j'étais là beaucoup
pleuré la citoyenne que je suis s'en est
réjouit je me réjouis de vivre dans un
pays où on ne met pas en prison des gens
lorsque le doute subsiste
c'est important quand même en France on
ne vit pas avec un sexisme systémique à
sa tête on n'est pas dans un pays qui
est dirigé par un sexisme systémique en
revanche il y a un sexisme systémique
qui demeure sur nos terres et à plein
d'endroits du monde c'est le sexisme
systémique religieux
parmi les trois religions il y a des
courants intégristes fondamentalistes
traditionalistes qui veulent faire
appliquer à la lettre des règles qui ont
un minimum 14 au siècles
d'existence ces règles-là ces règles qui
s'appuient sur la religion
sont des règles qui ont été conçues qui
ont été prévus à une époque où la
société était éminemment patriarcale
pour l'époque d'ailleurs ces règles ne
sont pas si absurdes que ça pour
aujourd'hui elles sont parfaitement
indignes et il faut vouloir lutter
contre ce fondamentalisme là absolument
lutter contre ce fondamentalisme ça veut
dire accepter d'aller défendre la
laïcité partout et tout le temps alors
attention je veux préciser ici que je ne
fais pas le procès de la croyance chacun
est libre de croire dans le dieu qu'il
veut il ne s'agit pas de juger cette
chose là c'est parfaitement intime le
procès que je fais c'est comme je le
décris dans mon dernier livre Le Péril
Dieu c'est le procès des marionnettistes
de droit divin c'est le procès de ceux
qui se sont chargés de faire advenir les
textes jusqu'à nous en gardant ce qui
leur arrangeait selon leurs intérêts
circonstanciés et selon les intérêts du
moment ce procès là je pense qu'il est
important de le faire encore une fois
Elisabeth ben dentaire a dit a écrit et
à répéter il n'y a pas de féminisme
possible sans une bonne part de laïcité
il suffit de voir encore aujourd'hui en
France
comment la religion a servi la femme à
l'étranger encore plus pour comprendre
qu'elle avait raison il faut absolument
relire Marjane Satrapi il faut
absolument relire Elisabeth Badinter il
faut pour ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu voir
ou revoir La journée de la jupe et puis
il y a le dernier livre que j'ai écrit
sur le féminisme qui s'appelait la paix
des sexes c'était avant le péril Dieu
dans lequel j'expliquais cette chose qui
me tient à cœur on ne peut pas être
libre seul on ne peut pas être libre
quand d'autres qui devraient être libre
autant que nous ne le sont pas on ne
peut pas être libre ici en France
maintenant quand partout sur le
territoire des hommes et des femmes
se servent de la religion pour opprimer
le féminin on ne peut pas être libre ici
et maintenant quand des femmes se voient
forcer de porter le voile on ne peut pas
être libre ici et maintenant quand des
femmes se voient obligés d'être mariées
à un âge qu'elles n'ont pas demandé avec
des hommes qu'elles n'ont pas demandé on
ne peut pas être libre ici et maintenant
quand on y rend des hommes et des femmes
crèvent de vouloir la même liberté que
nous on peut pas être libre ici et
maintenant quand un Afghanistan des
femmes sont en murées vivantes
alors pour conclure je voudrais vous
dire deux choses
la première est une conviction intime la
France ne sera jamais la première
puissance économique mondiale on n'a pas
les moyens de faire jeu égal ni avec les
États-Unis ni avec la Chine avec plein
d'autres pays en revanche la France est
ce pays qui a su en quatre jours faire
venir sur son sol 44 chefs d'État
étrangers pour défiler après les
attentats de Charlie Hebdo aucun autre
pays n'est capable de faire ça pourquoi
parce que partout dans le monde la
France c'est l'égalité la liberté
d'expression la laïcité
ça ne veut pas rien dire et ça nous
oblige on est très en dessous de notre
rôle en Iran avec laquelle on a un pays
avec lequel on a une histoire commune il
y a autre chose que je voudrais vous
dire c'est qu'il faudra à l'avenir en
gros d'ici 2027 peut-être faire très
attention à ne pas en s'opposant à une
radicalité sombrer dans la radicalité
inverse ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
y a des parties d'extrême droite
notamment qui sous couvert de défendre
la laïcité explique par exemple qu'il
faudrait interdire le voile dans
l'espace public nous ne sommes pas en
dictature même si intimement et
profondément mais idéaux égalitaires
refusent le symbole qu'elle le voile je
ne veux pas qu'on interdise le voile
dans l'espace public la première de
notre devise c'est liberté
il n'y a qu'un seul pays qui a fait ça
aucun autre pays n'interdit le voit il
n'y a qu'un seul pays qu'il a fait une
fois dans son histoire c'est l'Iran
c'est le premier chat d'Iran voilà le
résultat alors pour conclure je voudrais
juste pour conclure après la conclusion
je voudrais juste vous dire un petit mot
qui va peut-être illuminer un peu tout
ce pessimisme que j'ai sans doute
véhiculé j'étais la semaine dernière pas
plus tard que que lundi en Afrique avec
ma fille qui a 7 ans elle s'appelle
Tanya on était au Cameroun et elle a
adoré ce pays elle a découvert plein de
choses et au moment de partir elle m'a
dit maman il y a quand même quelque
chose qui me fait de la peine c'est que
partout partout tu as vu il y a des
enfants même des plus petits que moi
maman ils vendent des cacahuètes ils
vendent des bouteilles d'eau et il
demande des Francs CFA maman c'est pas
normal ils ont mon âge ils ont même
parfois plus petit que moi maman il
devrait pas avoir le besoin de demander
de l'argent
j'ai été très fière au fond de moi parce
que c'était avec ces mots de 7 ans
ce que je voudrais qu'on se dise tous à
tous les moments de nos vies on ne peut
pas être libre seul on ne peut pas être
libre ici et maintenant si quelqu'un
d'autre qui devrait être libre comme
nous ne l'est pas aussi merci de m'avoir
écouté
[Applaudissements]